what's your name
Alex how you are doing how was your day
so far we're doing really well thank you
masha'allah so you Muslim are you Muslim
because he wasn't very strict though
so are you Muslim uh no I'm not well
what belief do you have Christine and
you
you're Christian dude Christian Orthodox
are born again
huh
I don't really know the actual meaning
of it but
uh
uh do you believe in Jesus God no I
believe God yeah so you worship God In
The Name of Jesus or you should go
directly
that's good that's good more close to
East London than Christianity really
yeah I mean you're more close to be
honest you're close to the true teacher
of Jesus then Paul
you know poor
yeah Paul is it one of the rights of the
Gospel the spoon Mark Luke John Matthew
yeah Paul is one of the four is the one
to be honest majority of Christians our
time they don't know really for Jesus
they follow Paul
that's why you believe Jesus died for
your sins
yeah that's not Jesus teaching when a
young boy came to Jesus he said oh good
Master what should I do to inherit the
Kingdom of Heaven so the young boy he
was Jewish he was a healthy it was a for
me sorry it was wealthy person yeah it
was rich he was asking Jesus when we
mentioned Jesus we mentioned him with
the respectful and respectful way
Allah
bless him on him so the young boy said
to Jesus how can I attain
eternity which is in Paradise Jesus said
to him
follow the law of God okay or keep the
Commandments of God the Commandments of
God mean the Torah yes the young boy
said to him I have been doing it since I
was young
Jesus said to him you are lacking one
thing
he said what is it he said give you
wealth away and follow me so Jesus
clearly is telling the young boy to keep
the Commandments of God which many
Christians don't follow the Old
Testament anymore Jesus is telling the
young boy to follow the Old Testament
the Commandments of God and to give
charity and for Jesus teaching yes but
4K he said it's not about Commandments
of God it's not about the law anymore
it's about you having a faith Jesus died
for your sins
but Jesus never said that to the young
boy that believe I'm gonna die for your
sins you'll be saved you know that's why
if you study the issue of Christianity
you can as many Christian Scholars said
you can see there's differences between
Jesus teaching what actual Jesus
thoughts and what's full and the gospel
writers imagine Jesus teaching
you understand so because we live to
Jesus and like the prophets and the
messages before Jesus Moses Abraham Noah
Jacob they came to call people to
worship God Alone
and they came to you be responsible for
your sins
sorry
in uh so one of the books Nob numbers uh
what is it the other one I forgot the
name of the the ghost the the the the
the book in the Old Testament it says
even Genesis
if you commit sin you'll be responsible
for it
not God or I mean not Jesus died for you
or someone yes what do you do in
Christian and Judaism they slaughter the
Sheep but social ship is an act of
worship not the Sheep he's taking your
sins no when you start the ship that
experience of sins is understandable but
to say I'm gonna commit rape pedophilia
murder everything but guess what Jesus
died for my sins it's okay that doesn't
make any sense
in the stuff
it's not a good thing to think that's
true that's true yeah no that's 100 you
know that's why you know subhanallah
when you look to like I said Jesus
teaching and Prophet Muhammad teaching
because Muhammad same came with if you
commit sin you'll be responsible for it
Allah has a vast Mercy Allah a huge
Mercy you know God is how much things
you do Allah's Mercy is greater than
your sins so don't ever give up you know
and if you commit sin what you do you
repent to God
try your best to not go back to it and
if you take if you did take something
from someone you give it back to him
being the better person
Jesus who is innocent person let me give
you an example imagine you came and took
my phone stole my phone
so what I do to forgive you I go and
punish him I might just
not just because why just to give
everyone what he deserves he doesn't
deserve he never did nothing to me so
why in Christianity we Jesus
according to Paul Jesus became cursed
and he was punished because of the sins
of the people but I never commit sin
that doesn't make any sense
you see that's why we believe that the
Romans and poor one of them they
corrupted the true teacher of Jesus
that's why the Bible has been changed
many times that's when it comes to Islam
Islam is pure it's perfect you know the
Quran that we have 100 million of
Muslims memorize the Quran word for word
later for later you know no one can
trust the Quran literally if the Jews
and the Muslims and the Christians now
decided to burn their scriptures
the only scripture will remain with us
is the Quran you know how because we
memorized it by hearts
you understand so when you look to
Islamic teaching why we believe Prophet
Muhammad is a true prophet and so if
we're taking your time by the way I'm
gonna conclude with this inshallah if
you have any question you can ask pay
attention to this yeah Islam came to
preserve five Universal necessities
five Universal Necessities Islam came to
preserve first one Islam came to
preserve religion what does that mean it
means that in Islam it is forbidden it
is a major sin it is the greatest thing
to do to not worship the true God
because when you worship the true God
I'm gonna demonstrate what is the
outcome and also I'm going to
demonstrate to you what is the opposite
of not worshiping the true God so Islam
comes to worship God when also Prophet
Muhammad we don't pray in the name of
Muhammad prophet Muhammad we pray we
pray in the name of Allah who is Allah
the creator of everything the king of
the Kings you know so Islam came to
preserve religion
Islam came to preserve the intellect
what does that mean it means alcohol and
drugs and anything that harms intellect
in Islam is forbidden yeah okay Islam
came to preserve wealth
what does that mean gambling and an
interest is forbidden and I'll explain
the Abba gambling and so on why Islam
came to preserve
marriage
that's when is the fornication adultery
is forbidden Islam came to preserve life
that's why killing people unjustly or
harming your body or committing suicide
is forbidden these five things if we
preserve them we will have a healthy and
good Society what is the opposite of
that when you do not worship the true
God you start allowing drugs gambling
interest fornication interest waste
interest interest make the rich Richa
poor poorer
interest is a new type of slavery
I so I do I know if I give you five
thousand pounds because you are in need
of it
I know by next week you will never be
able to give it back to me because I
study you yeah so I always say to you
look next you give it to me six thousand
pound or seven thousand Pounds by next
week I come to you I said where's my
money by the way my name is
Alex you have good memories
Ashton give me seven thousand pounds but
you know what because you cannot give it
to me now I'll give you two weeks more
but this time give me twenty thousand
pounds and I know so I'm doing imagine
putting that in a big scale I'm doing it
to him to him to him to him so what I'm
doing I'm making myself richer and I'm
utilizing people's need to manipulate
them but Islam teach us that if
someone's in need of help don't utilize
his need help him for the sake of Allah
even we have a beautiful narration from
our Prophet Muhammad
said Allah will say to the people in day
of judgment Allah will say to the people
in their judgments I ask you to feed me
but you never fed me so the person will
say oh Allah you are the creator of
everything you're the provider how can I
feed you Allah will say my my servants
so and so who is in need of food but you
never fed him if you fed him I will help
you today
you see likewise in other words I've
asked you to clothe me but you never
clothed me you will say Allah how can I
clothe you you are the almighty the
Creator Allah will say to him my friend
sorry my servants was in need of
garments of clothes but you never gave
him clothes
Islam Islam teach us the Muslim like one
body if any part of the body feel pain
the rest of the body feel pain you know
that's why now we have to understand
that why there's a huge war against
Islam because this voice I have
mentioned gambling interest alcohol
drugs a fornication destroy societies
but yes there's yet there are some
people who does benefit from them who
are they those in power
so those in power they see Islam as a
threat for their business because Islam
not just coming to forbid it Islam
there's punishment for anyone that
breaks those laws because if we break
the laws these five Necessities you
destroy yourself and Society
so they look at Islam as a threat for
their business because they are rich so
what they do they use their money to
make Islam look bad through the media
and this is what's happening now
that's why there's a usual Angus Islam
because the only rules that standing
firm and guess evil ones what do you
think was said so far does it make sense
it does yes and the question you ask
yourself is well how men that existed
1400 years ago that is Prophet Muhammad
yeah who couldn't read and write his
communities a perfect way of life on the
other hand we have these politicians
around the world in America Britain
France you name it who studied in the
best universities around the world yet
the Khan notorious of the problems you
are facing because Prophet Muhammad is a
messenger of the creator of everything
and the creator of everything he knows
what is good for us in details and what
is bad for us in details that is one of
the proofs to establish why Islam is the
truth and why Prophet Muhammad is a
message of Allah
yeah so this guy yes this brother is our
brother know Islam of course he says
official agree with but to be honest he
said many things which is right you know
why because this man was a multi is a
multi-millionaire he he said something
which I always use it he said I saw the
devil with my own eyes
you know what he meant because when he
was so rich he was involved with with
the
secret societies or top people and he
saw what they do and he said you know
what I I have noticed the only religion
that is standing firm against this evil
one is Islam
he was a Christian he said that's why I
become a Muslim
yes he says things which would argue
with because due to his lack of
knowledge he's still learning remember
he came from crazy background
crazy last night but to be honest many
things he said which for me from our
human nature which himself he said you
know what I believe Islam agree with me
not everything
but now what's happening now there's the
evil ones they want to destroy our
nature bro
our human nature literally now that
people cannot even Define what is woman
so literally now what I can do I can
beat up a woman rather says Haram Islam
and if you come say you beat up a woman
I said define a woman
if you define this as a woman she has a
she was born with a breast and other
things yeah I said what about the men
identify woman are you against them they
say you're because if you say that you
see look how it's crazy it's getting you
know but Allah mentioned that in the
Quran long time ago the Allah mentioned
the Satan will inspire people to just
Allah to change Allah's creation
you know imagine you know there's I'm
not sure if you heard about it there was
a man who raped two women
oh yeah have you heard about it then
he's going to the courts now he's going
to the court they have to
sends him to go prison he wants dressed
like a woman he said I identify myself
as a woman now what I have to do they
have to put in prison which prison you
that's it and for him it's Paradise
that's what he wants but look Allah said
if the truth follow people desires the
heavens and the Earth be corrupted look
what's happening confusion
like literally I can say listen bro I
believe I'm a lion literally I'm a tiger
but I'm trapped in a human body and
every time you have to speak to me you
have to deal with me like a tiger you
know and I can do things to people and
the police can arrest me because I'm a
tiger you know it's all crazy it's crazy
it's getting crazy it's unbelievable
that's what I'm saying Islam there's no
salvation for us except by following
Islam's teaching
you know Christianity like I said I
believe in Jesus no doubt it's a mighty
messenger but Jesus is not Christian
Christianity was made up by the Romans
they changed Jesus teaching they're
corrupted it the Bible that we have we
can we don't even have it in the pure
language of Jesus we have it in
different language but the Quran that we
have is the same Quran that Prophet
Muhammad recited to his companions is
the same one you know do you have any
questions by the way
ask any question man welcome to you from
by the way that's how your father
do you speak Arabic
uh I used to when I was very young
because Egyptians there's a lot of
there's Christians as well in Egypt
I think it's a mainly Islam country
yeah yeah you're right yeah yeah
in Syria you know that's why we're here
for we're here basically to explain what
Islam is the truth and so for people to
become Muslim to worship God imagine say
to you
I've been speaking to all of you for
maybe 10 15 minutes yeah I'm a
multi-millionaire I really like you guys
I'm gonna give you two million pounds as
a gift
if I if you do take it what would you
say to me
if you do take two million pounds would
you thank me
thank you but I'd also be kind of scared
yeah but if you do if you do take it you
attending of course if you do take it
you will remember me all the time two
million pound is a big money yes yes
please skeptical it's good because I'm
gonna give you two million pounds on the
condition give me your two eyes would
you do that no go because why your eyes
is more valuable than 2 million pounds
so while we're not grateful and remember
who gave us eyes for free
the second question yes we want to be
grateful to God you want to be you want
to worship Him the question you ask
yourself if you want to buy a gift for
your mother would you buy a gift that
your love for your mother love
likewise if you want to worship with the
Creator and be grateful to him we should
worship him the way he loves because the
way he loves is objective the way we
love is subjective that's why he sent
the prophets and Messengers like Moses
Abraham Noah Jesus the last of the
Prophet Muhammad so you want to worship
God if you want to worship according to
his teaching that is an Islamic teacher
because it's been preserved that's for
the Bible has been corrupted
if I tell you what a stop ready to
become Muslim why would you answer
what's
up yeah to become a worship of God the
true God correctly
what is stopping you yeah
well I have actually noticed before
people have talked to me about Islam
especially in re class yeah I find it to
be much more interesting than
Christianity yeah because as you said
there's more people with Christianity
that's right words haven't been tainted
yeah
that's right that's what I really like
about it yeah the fact that everything
that's been said has been said the whole
time yeah
I'd say I'd be more willing to join
Islam than Christianity yeah yeah of
course you know you're saying that my
wife is a re-read by the way my wife she
was a Christian okay she became Muslim
before I met her yet and her mother
she's an atheist
I'm about to be honest she's confused
when the atheist when they're Christian
I don't know you know but her stepfather
is atheist both of them said if we want
to choose any religion we will choose
Islam
right that's why I said you know you
know when God when God creates us they
create us with something called
Universal tools
what is universal tools sound reasoning
you know if you allow our sound
reasoning and our natural inclination to
cooperate the way God created them
naturally will gravitate towards Islam
why because the one that creates you
with those tools is the same one who
sent down Islam that's why
so you bring many keys because
Christianity Judaism Hinduism try to
open this battle that you have within
you it doesn't open it when you come to
Islam
perfect because the one who made that
fat Block in you is the same one who
sent out that key which is the
revelation
you understand and Islam is a practical
it's not just being in the church that's
it no Islam is not just for the people
for the government too
because when the people start following
their desires
then what happened just again mixed up
I'll give you example to demonstrate to
you yeah you know I can go off license
yes alcohol yes
I can go
you know like before I was I sell drugs
before that alhamdul I changed for many
years if I go sell drugs outside of
license
the police will come arrest me but I
want to arrest the shopkeeper even
though we are selling the same item or
different item but it costs the same
harm
okay alcohol the law of crimes is being
carried out because of alcohol yes
alcohol harms our body okay so why the
drug dealer gets arrested and the
shopkeeper is not getting arrested when
above them are selling something which
harm our bodies
because alcohol there's high taxes on it
they're making money for me
themselves
I mean Divine Law
and don't be scared by this what's
happening around the world of Australia
it's coming to kill everyone that is a
lie yes there is some Muslims who are
foolish ones who misunderstand Islam Who
Lies against Islam they are Muslims but
they are ignorance Islam they say we're
coming to take over this country to
implement Sharia which is something
there's aspect of which only for the
leaders and the government we're not
here to do that because we know the
authority we understand this is Allah
against Islam you know these people I
believe there are some some of them some
of them are hypocrites but anyway Sharia
there's many aspects us show you how to
take care of your mother and Sharia to
take care you know in Islam imagine you
work in the street and you see something
blocking people's path
if you remove it
you got good Allah because why you are
helping the people you try to take care
of the people taking care of your mother
which is one of the greatest good deed
in Islam is from Sharia but Sharia
holistically
when you look at it Sharia comes to deal
with the problems from The Roots
humans law
is like when you go to a doctor and it
gives you party
what he's just doing he's just tried to
manage his symptoms he's not dealing
with the problem from The Roots so Islam
Sharia I deal with the problems
but human law just likes to cover the
problem is still there but it's just to
cover it you understand because Allah is
the know of everything humans they don't
know everything they have deficiency
understand so like I said so when it
comes to the Islam like I said because
in loud sound reason much inclination
and it goes in line with our human
nature generally speaking you know so
advice to become Muslim bro you become
Muslim
that's what he gives Quran as well you
want to read more yes you can become
Muslim today then read more after up to
you I'm gonna put pressure on you but I
will say to you brother you said you
make sense to you I mean all of you
alone my point here is you said you make
sense to you what I would say to you how
old are you by the way
okay my wife should become Muslim when
she was 14. I don't remember exactly
yeah she was younger than Europe and she
said it did not make sense to me that
Jesus is God praying to God and other
teaching you know let's go for someone
she said I become Muslim you know so and
not and online three weeks ago
three weeks a month ago there was a
young boy his mother became a Muslim
before him he was 11 years old he became
Muslim with us
he had that because why you want to
connect yourself to your creator well I
was going to say you never know you're
going to die how many people left the
house they never come back
how many people won't sleep they never
wake up you understand are you
guaranteed to leave tomorrow
you're not guaranteed bro and this stuff
is a test when Allah created his life
Allah has attributes mercy and love
forgiveness and God Mighty Allah create
Paradise which is based upon his mercy
and love then Allah create the Hellfire
which is based upon his anger and mighty
and Allah Allah creates Paradise which
is pure good create the Hellfire who's
Pure Evil and they create this life evil
and good so it's for us to decide to
which place should we which path it's a
good path the good path in this Dunya in
this life will lead you to Paradise
because you know like I said there are
people like us today just us talking
joking have a nice conversation they are
dead now in the graves and that's not
the end who says day of judgments and
the biggest sin against Allah will
return away from him
if someone
if someone Islam was explained to him
foreign
[Music]
you would take me straight away
let me give you another example imagine
the house
or you could tonight you go to your own
room you wake up by the morning and
there is a fire everywhere
everywhere you try your best to Serve
Yourself
and you couldn't you gave up I came and
I saved your life what would you say to
me
yeah you're gonna remember me you're not
gonna say to me give me time to remember
your thank you I never gave you life
what about the one who gave your life
for free what about the one who gave you
life for free
that's it you know so therefore and the
way to be extendful to him is by
following Islamic teaching I could
demonstrate so what you
read the Quran I read the Quran many
times yeah but I don't have to know
everything about Islam to accept the
foundation which is clear that there's
only one God because I even as a
preacher I'm still learning you know but
what we tell you what we have explained
to you so far is Islamic Foundation
whatever you're going to learn it goes
back to this Foundation you have learned
Islam
because rather they get happy after you
know what it's true especially when you
pray you know we'll go through hardship
you pray five times a day imagine I said
to you every time you come to my house
I'll give you twenty thousand pounds yes
oh I'm gonna come every day man what
about the one you pray to your creator
and every time you pray you're getting
blessings your sins been removed and you
get a refresh and re-energized
you cannot be deluded by slogans
and deception you know like I say
freedom what does it mean freedom to
become slave of desires or slave Society
the true freedom to become a servant of
your creator so I will say to you bro if
you make sense to you please learn
become Muslim to become Muslim there's
two testimony that you say which I have
broken it down for you but there's no
one worthy of worship except Allah
and I bear with this Muhammad the
messenger of Allah and the rest of the
pillars pray and so on it comes back to
these two pillars that I should be
grateful I should worship my Creator and
I should worship Him according to the
teacher of the last prophet is Muhammad
that's how you become Muslim then step
by step you start learning bro we're
like you know imagine you die today my
love forbid yeah
what would be your excuse before your
God for not accepting the truth that you
think will be valid
no it's not accepting the truth yeah
except in Islam which you know you
recognize is true foreign
what would you say to the God Almighty
the creator of everything which excuse
you think by saying it to your God will
save you from his punishment
or so that you didn't know for sure that
it was real when you were alive but now
that you're in his presence it's real
that's all you're saying no I'm saying
that imagine now because you say it
makes sense to you yeah and you believe
that's the truth yeah yeah okay so
imagine a day of judgment God said to
you okay imagine you die today my love
forbid and you have not accept Islam so
I haven't converted yeah you haven't
converted yeah you know the word you
haven't converted and God said to you
why did not convert when the truth was
clear to you
what excuse what's reason you think if I
say to God will save you from his
punishment I'm not really sure I don't
really think I have nothing there's
nothing we're like you know what I
always use this to make you reflect on
yourself that Nothing is Stopping You
except it's the whisper of the devil
Prophet Muhammad told us when someone
wants to become Muslim because
true servant of the creator of
everything Satan isn't going to stop
stop whispering to your mind
he will try to bring anything about your
family that's why I always mention this
example or this thing the reason people
don't accept Islam even makes sense to
them and it's clear he boils down to two
factors either is a psychological factor
meaning the Arrogant or they like to do
some evil things which Islam forbids you
know or social Factor because they're
scared if they become Muslim their
family would engage them and so on but
none of these factors will save you
before God you're a big man understand
you're 15 or 16. 16 bro you understand
you're a big person you know so 16 you
have your own choice you can make your
own decision so this is not a joke this
is a serious matter of life or hell and
Paradise that's why I invite you to
become Muslim but like I said I'm just
explaining to you and I'm saying to you
look it makes sense you believe the
truth become Muslim and even yourself
you said before you gravitate towards
Islam than Christianity
so become Muslim inshallah and then
learn step by step
ready
you want to become Muslim yeah yeah when
I go home
if you go home I mean I want to get a
reward but look I don't want to put in
pressure yeah if it makes sense and you
believe the truth and you say no watch
me see I believe it's true then it comes
with them now we tell you what to say
which is you agreed with and you accept
it that Islam is the truth and then when
you go home you learn more
[Music]
yeah I can see your your goodness enough
I mean all of you but I can see you are
like a more you have any questions
yeah ask any question that you want
because
um
that's why he wasn't corrupted in a way
because he couldn't read or write you
can read some books from people who work
around like the people that have been
Rich you know the rich people yeah
corrupted by their words because they've
made it you know he's gonna think that
not him specifically but people are
gonna think that that's how you get to
that position that's right no you used
to we say yeah you you're right but we
say that is a proof because he couldn't
read them right so all this information
he brought to mankind where you got it
from he cannot read it and he couldn't
write or none of that write it down so
therefore the Muslim Scholars use this
that he couldn't learn and write to show
he must be a messenger of the most high
like I said about the five things I came
to preserve all this information all
this uh conduct and a live
rules and regulations that kind of comes
from a normal human being bro especially
it's perfect and it makes sense and it's
good for us individually collectively
so that's you you know what you're doing
you are making our belief Stronger by
using arguments you should be completely
better today now we'll let you know
mashallah
if I look to
okay I will sit I will take it or I will
go I and I think a little bit then I
come back and took it
what do you think what about the diamond
the diamond you saw the diamond in this
the Earth and oh I have to think a
little bit oh because it just needs a
person
exactly that's it that's what this is
yeah it's basically saying that of
course if you see a diamond you know
it's having very valuable valuable I
mean put aside someone dropped it or
something if you see something valuable
you're not gonna think you know let me
go home and come back take it you will
take it it's not very valuable of course
except if you think you know someone
dropped it but even if someone dropped
it you would take it to protect it so
Islamic teaching that's who should have
present to you is more valuable than
that it's your life this is based upon
your life you know
look you mentioned a good point um
that's why we use Prophet Muhammad
couldn't read and write and it's coming
it's a perfect way of life it's
impossible to come from a normal human
being it must be the message of Allah
and Allah the creator of everything he
will not choose a liar to convey his
message you know how many years we've
been cutting or been cut off from
worshiping the true God you know and
look while we speaking we are benefiting
from God's uh blessings the air the
oxygen your eyes you know the liquid and
everything in our eyes the liquid in our
ears all of that in the stand so he's
like I understand because I've been
doing this for the last 15 years some
people say yeah give me time then they
become Muslim but some people they
become straight away and I'm telling you
I've experience for the last 15 years no
one ever came to me and says you know
what I'm saying I regret people becoming
a Muslim rather that's why we don't say
convert we say reverse mean you're going
back to your original states but because
you are born in a Christian family or
not Islamic family then they teach you
the wrong things but Allah will not
judge you base because of that now
because you're a big man you have your
own knowledge you have your own
intellect you have your own choice so
you either accept or reject but to go
home and do it you can do it here I'm
doing it and do less but I always
emphasize bro make sense is the truth
and it's clear to you become Muslim
because shaytan should stop you
you know just not one English
name how old is
still you become Muslim
s yeah yeah
and then you're from here
okay all of you from Cardiff
huh where are you from
where
Bulgaria ah Bulgaria okay okay
do you have other questions
so you're ready to become Muslim now
okay
when you leave because you see all of
your smart boys yeah when you leave
don't take this information and just you
know no you have to you have the book
and even in that book it tells you how
to become Muslim understand but if you
think you know what I want to be more
sure with myself and then operation you
know so if you have no questions nothing
yeah okay
you have questions
and there you go very nice discussion
though you know I pray to Allah bless
all of you you know but it was my
pleasure talking to you I literally
enjoyed the conversation with you a lot
man have a nice weekend yeah